bonsoir et merci d'être en direct avec
nous ce soir sur rtl france seize
départements sont donc concernés dont
l'île de france et donc paris où vous
êtes conseiller municipal en quoi la
fermeture des commerces dinin
essentielle peut aider à freiner
l'épidémie décision de confinement est
un aveu d'échec majeure du gouvernement
personne n'y comprend plus rien qu'elles
sont on ne sait même pas quel commerce
vont être fermés ou ouverts hier soir
les coiffeurs étaient fermés ils sont
ouverts aujourd'hui première nécessité
jusqu'où on sait bien que plus les
commerces ont réduit plus les gens vont
se concentrer au même endroit même heure
et donc vont augmenter le taux de
reproduction du virus alors qu'au
contraire il fallait peut-être élargir
donc cette confusion générale elle est
incompréhensible
aujourd'hui les français attendent de la
clarté ça fait six mois que nous savons
que les vaccins existent cela fait trois
mois que les vaccins sont disponibles
et puis nous avons vu l'union européenne
mal les gauchers et après l'état
français l'administration de la santé
raté à nouveau de l'étape des vaccins
nous avons raté l'étape des masques en
2020 rappelez vous on a raté les tables
des des tests puis de la traçabilité est
aujourd'hui nous ratons l'étape des
vaccins la france est un des pays les
plus en retard de l'union européenne
dans la vaccination de sa population
nous savons que c'est la course contre
la montre nous avons voulait bien sûr
sur la problématique des commerçants on
apprend ce soir que les fleuristes les
chocolatiers les cordonniers sont
ajoutés à la liste des commerces qui
resteront ouverts bercy l'annoncent ce
soir vous vous évoquez un manque de
clarté comment est-ce que vous expliquer
ce manque de cohérence et disparités
entre les commerces dits essentiels non
essentiels le gouvernement est pris en
étau entre une administration de la
santé un mammouth de la santé qui lui
donne plein de directives
contradictoires
et puis le fait qu'il n'y a pas de
stratégie et qui menait le maquereau est
visiblement hésite tergiverse retarde
avance et improvise au gré de ce que
l'un ou l'autre lui dis donc il n'y a
pas de cap
il n'y a pas de stratégie claire les
commerçants sont en train de mourir
les petits commerçants qui sont depuis
c'est la troisième fois qu'on les faire
de manière arbitraire son qu'il ya une
logique derrière très clair soit on a un
confinement
très dur comme en mars 2020 soit on n'a
pas un compliment est au contraire on
cherche à diluer les rencontres donc les
commerçants sont perdus les clients les
français sont paumés aussi personne ne
sait très bien combien de temps ça va
durer ou on va pourquoi les vaccins sont
pas là je vous rappelle que l'annoncent
de 7,2 ce confinement qui mais on n'est
pas à un visiblement pas reculer le
maquereau a dit que ce n'était pas un
confinement
c'était un freinage du virus on sait
plus très bien quelle manche choisir il
intervient à un moment où l'état
français a suspendu la vaccination du
vaccin à trois et des cas qui a fait ses
preuves en angleterre elle a remarqué
matin donc vous comprenez on a perdu une
semaine mais une semaine c'est énorme on
est déjà le pays le plus en retard de
l'union européenne ce gouvernement est
fou enfin je crois que la la la la
responsabilité de la bureaucratie de la
santé va devoir être traitée d nous
serons sortis du coc vide parce que
c'est pas supportable d'être pris en
otage les commerces les artisans les
restaurants et les bars et les français
par des gens qui sont aussi maladroit à
côté de la plaque depuis un an
l'exécutif se targue depuis plusieurs
semaines maintenant de consulter les
élus locaux
comment est-ce que les choses se sont
organisés ces derniers jours à la mairie
de paris notamment et dans la mesure où
les décisions sanitaires sont
aujourd'hui territorialisées quel poids
est ce que vous avez pour adapter à
paris par exemple les nouvelles
restrictions
d'abord je ne vous cache pas que c'est
difficile de savoir ce qui se passe à
paris parce que la maire de paris
communique très peu avec les maires donc
les maires d'arrondissement et les élus
d'opposition ne sont pas au courant de
grand chose
c'est très improvisés je rappelle qu'il
ya un an la maire de paris avait annoncé
que ce n'était pas son périmètre la
santé qu'elle ne voulait pas nettoyé et
aseptisée le mobilier urbain aujourd'hui
la maire de paris veut s'impliquer mais
elle ne parle à personne moi je peux pas
vous donner l'information j'en ai pas
après au niveau de l'état je pense que
cette ce discours de décentralisation
c'est une blague nous avons des ars qui
sont pilotés par l'état central
en fait toute la politique de santé
reste centralisée et qu'on l'état
demande son avis à des élus locaux
c'est pas pour écouter ce que les haines
legault à dire c'est pour essayer de
faire passer la pilule mais
franchement personne ne croit
aujourd'hui à une décentralisation des
mesures chaque région obéit à ce que le
ministère de la santé et cette
bureaucratie a choisi est-ce qu'on peut
évaluer aujourd'hui ce que va
représenter cette nouvelle fermeture
pour les commerçants concernés que
représente déjà aujourd'hui les derniers
confinement sur leurs finances
combien de commerçants sont au bout du
rouleau n'ont plus de trésorerie ont
commencé à emprunter auprès de leurs
amis de leurs amis pour tenir le coup là
et voyez la fin du tunnel
on leur a fait miroiter la fin du tunnel
on leur a promis que les vaccins étaient
là et aujourd'hui on referme tout je
crois que malheureusement ça va pousser
à beaucoup de faillites à des
dépressions une situation humaine
sociale catastrophique ces gens qui
pourtant sont le l'animation la vitalité
du du pays
je suis très inquiet je vous avoue que
cette décision ne surprend et je suis
très inquiète pour l'avenir de nos
commerces de la vitalité urbaine rurale
parce que ces commerces ils font vivre
le pays entier c'est eux qui animent nos
quartiers c'est eux qui créent du lien
social
tout ça est très inquiétant elle aurait
été la meilleure solution puisque vous
évoquez est finalement une mesures
beaucoup plus radicales un confinement
nationale non non non je crois que la
course était d'abord de réussir la
course au vaccin
la priorité depuis six mois depuis six
mois qu'on sait que ces vaccins sont là
c'était de négocier l'achat très rapide
de nos dizaines de millions de doses et
puis ensuite laissé les pharmaciens les
médecins les hôpitaux les centres
municipaux tous les organisations
capables de tenir le choc d'assurer la
vaccination c'était ça la priorité
moi je veux maintenant on est on est
dans d'enliser dans situation
catastrophique on a des vaccins qui sont
pas utilisés on vient de perdre une
semaine maintenant voilà on est dans nos
murs on peut juste féliciter le
gouvernement d'avoir raté toutes les
étapes
c'est malheureux merci beaucoup d'avoir
pris le temps de réagir ce soir sur arte
france aurélien véron conseiller
municipal et républicains à la mairie de
paris